Traduttore: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Federico Sangati
Buonasera
(Musica)
La vita è andare all'incontrario
su un tappeto mobile.
Cammini e stai fermo.
Stai fermo e vai all'indietro.
Per andare avanti
devi farti fretta.
Mi chiamo Giulio Michelon.
Il video che avete visto
è di un regista americano
che vive a New York.
Si chiama Casey Neistat.
Per chi di voi non si intende
bene con l'inglese
in breve dice che la vita
è come un nastro trasportatore.
Se state fermi vi trascina,
se camminate riuscite
a rimanere nello stesso punto,
l'unica maniera per avanzare è correre.
Tenete a mente queste immagini,
ci torneremo alla fine del talk.
Ora però vorrei raccontarvi una storia.
Quattro anni fa mi diplomo
al liceo scientifico.
Uno si aspetta, a quell'età,
un'idea sul futuro,
una passione da seguire, un sogno,
sia la via più semplice da trovare.
Qualcosa!
Qualche sogno...
Nel mio caso non era assolutamente così.
Io sapevo solo cosa non volevo fare:
Chimica.
Non sono mai stato molto
in gamba in Chimica.
E quindi, mentre tutti i miei amici
decidevano secondo le loro passioni
- chi voleva diventare pilota d'aerei
chi salvare la Foresta Amazzonica,
chi voleva costruire grattacieli -
io semplicemente cercavo la cosa meno
vincolante possibile per il mio futuro.
Insomma, dopo il liceo,
l'ennesima "non scelta" della mia vita.
Ed è così che decido
di iscrivermi ad Economia
Una scelta assennata, rigorosa,
lungimirante.
E, d'altronde, nessuno ti può davvero
dire nulla se tu studi i soldi.
E insomma, così mi iscrivo e,
nonostante la mia scarsissima convinzione,
riesco ad entrare
e a passare il test di Economia,
qui, proprio all'Universtà di Trento.
Tutto contento con i miei amici
prenotiamo il viaggio di Maturità,
come insomma tutti i ragazzi giovani,
salvo poi scoprire,
esattamente il giorno prima del volo,
che ho sbagliato l’iscrizione
di ben due settimane.
Immaginate come potessi
sentirmi al momento.
Inizio a girare
di segreteria in segreteria
per cercare di sistemare la situazione
e mi spiegano che il mio posto,
dopo numerosi ripescaggi,
perché, insomma,
due settimane sono lunghe,
era stato dato alla persona
con un punteggio inferiore,
ma che sa leggere le date.
Eh già!
E quindi che si fa?
E quindi mi danno in mano
un depliant dell’Università e dicono:
“Bene ragazzo.
Scegli una facoltà a numero aperto
e, nel momento in cui qualcuno
ad Economia molla,
puoi subentrare te.”
“Benissimo!” dico.
Apro il depliant dell'Università,
salto a piè pari Ingegneria
per l'eccessiva presenza di Chimica
e tra Fisica, Filosofia, Lettere,
Matematica e Informatica
inizio a decidere che cosa fare.
L'informatica mi è sempre interessata,
ma un interesse diciamo da entusiasta.
Un po' da fuori, ecco.
Diciamo che se il liceo scientifico
mi aveva dato dei chiari segnali
rispetto alle mie scarse capacità
in Chimica,
avevo avuto delle sensazioni simili
anche per Matematica,
materia fondamentale ad Informatica.
Infatti poi alla fine decido...
informatica.
Perché vi sto raccontando questa storia?
Perché io credo che il coraggio di osare
stia proprio in questo:
trovarsi in una situazione
di estremo sfavore
e decidere di prendersi dei rischi
per riuscire a cavarne fuori
qualcosa di buono.
Da questi rischi potrebbero
succedere cose anche peggiori.
Però io credo che,
quando le opportunità bussano alla porta,
vadano colte, vadano percorse.
E nel mio caso io ancora non lo sapevo
ma l'Informatica
- perché poi non subentrai
mai più ad Economia -
mi avrebbe portato lontano.
Molto lontano.
Flash forward di un paio d'anni:
mi trovo alla sede di 500 Startup,
uno degli incubatori d'impresa
più brillanti e prestigiosi
della Silicon Valley
e sto dialogando con Eduardo Saverin.
Eduardo Saverin,
che possiede il 15% di Facebook.
Uno che quando a Facebook c'erano
lui, Mark Zuckerberg e pochi altri,
si potevano sedere tutti
attorno a un tavolo per decidere:
"Ma allora come lo facciamo?
Ci mettiamo i commenti, i mi piace?
Sì, molto bello."
Lui era là.
Ma come c'ero arrivato?
Grazie all'Università di Trento
sono riuscito ad accedere
a un tirocinio di tre mesi a Eversnap,
una startup americana.
Lì sono venuto a contatto
con tutto quel tessuto imprenditoriale,
quella voglia di creare cose incredibile
che è la Silicon Valley.
Ho conosciuto persone
che influenzano la vita
di milioni di persone
grazie ai prodotti che costruiscono.
Inutile dirlo, una volta tornato a casa,
l'unica cosa che volevo fare
era far partire la mia startup.
Di cosa si sarebbe occupata,
con chi farla, come si fa una startup:
questi erano tutti problemi secondari
E quindi dovendo rischiare in alto.
Scelgo per il meglio.
Qual'è incubatore d'impresa,
o acceleratore, più famoso d'Italia?
Per chi non lo sapesse
un acceleratore d'impresa è una struttura
che permette alle startup,
in cambio di una piccola quota societaria,
di crescere più velocemente,
da cui il nome acceleratore.
Grazie a queste strutture
le startup prendono velocità
e riescono a diventare poi quello
che poi sono diventate.
E quindi dovendo rischiare
scelgo per il migliore.
Si è quotato due settimane fa
nella Borsa italiana,
si chiama H-Farm.
A questo punto tutti i problemi
che avevo detto prima
iniziano ad emergere,
quindi cerco dei soci.
Inizio a cercare tra quelli
del mio corso che conoscevo,
e mi rivolgo a Luca D'Incà,
un amico con cui avevo già collaborato
brevemente in precedenza,
e con ragazzo che non conoscevo tanto
però aveva un curriculum
di tutto rispetto,
infatti lavorava
per un'azienda di videogiochi:
Giovanni Frigo.
Assieme a loro
- ricordo era un caldissimo agosto -
iniziamo a costruire questa app
che ci avrebbe aperto le porte
del successo internazionale.
E giorno dopo giorno
in salotto ideiamo questa app
che si chiama "Degusto".
Attraverso il tablet puoi vedere
tutte le cose del ristorante:
tutti i piatti del ristorante,
posso vedere le foto,
se sono un turista posso
vedere la traduzione,
poi, andando avanti,
potevamo farlo anche ordinare.
Andiamo avanti,
costruiamo il prototipo,
andiamo con le slide,
prepariamo tutto quanto.
H-Farm, dopo avergli mandato tutto quanto,
si interessa.
Un paio di Skype call e da lì si aspetta.
Si aspetta per un paio di settimane
l'email, quella che ti cambia la vita,
l'email quella dei film.
Dopo un paio di settimane
l'email arriva...e ci hanno scartati.
Sconforto.
Ed è proprio in questo momento,
come in quello precedente,
che decido che se una strada
non si può percorrere,
ce ne sono mille altre.
E insieme a Giovanni e Luca,
con i quali ci eravamo trovati
molto bene a lavorare,
decidiamo di andare in una direzione
un po' più solida.
Il bagno di realtà
che ci aveva fatto H-Farm,
peraltro legittimo,
tutte le motivazioni corrette
siete troppo giovani,
il prodotto troppo all'inizio,
insomma c'ho 23 anni, erano cose corrette.
E quindi decidiamo di andare
verso un business più solido,
più tranquillo,
qualcosa che ci permetta
di iniziare a far girare la ruota subito.
Facciamo sul serio.
Prendiamo un ufficio,
un piccolo ufficio qua a Trento
e i pomeriggi che prima passavamo
in salotto da me
iniziano a diventare giornate in ufficio,
e ci proponiamo
come società di consulenza.
La fortuna ci viene incontro
e dopo poco tempo
il nostro primo lavoro.
Il sito di una startup americana.
Da lì passo dopo passo,
mattone dopo mattone,
un sito un po' più grande,
una cosa più interessante,
iniziamo a muoverci verso le app.
Iniziano a contattarci
le aziende, quelle serie, quelle grandi,
quelle che i lavori non durano più
qualche settimana, durano dei mesi.
E le cose vanno bene,
ci costituiamo come società.
Stiamo per assumere le prime persone.
Insomma non siamo la Microsoft,
ma è un buon inizio!
(Applausi)
Grazie!
Ma torniamo al titolo di questo talk.
Nel caso qualcuno di voi l'avesse letto è:
"Come ho mandato un cane nello spazio".
Perché un cane?
Giulio, non ci hai detto nulla
che riguardi cani finora.
Beh, dopo Laica,
non tutti conoscono la storia,
sono stati mandati
numerosi cani nello spazio.
Il secondo, in particolare,
è stato quello che ha dato il nome
alla nostra azienda.
Ed è qui secondo me è la chiave
di lettura di tutto questo.
Solo il fatto di poter immaginare,
un giorno,
di guardare il proprio cane e dirgli:
"Sai che c'è? Volevamo farti fare
un giro 18 volte attorno alla terra
per farti tornare, nella cuccia,
come prima".
Insomma, io credo che il coraggio di osare
stia proprio in questo:
nel vedere delle strade dove non ci sono
assolutamente delle strade,
nel continuare a percorrerle,
nell'andare avanti
e a forza di continuare
a spingere e crederci e come
- vi ricordate il video all'inizio?
Quello che vi dicevo,
che, se si continua a camminare,
si resta fermi,
ma se si corre, se si continua
ad andare avanti,
allora li si può anche riuscire
a mandare un cane nello spazio.
L'importante è riuscire
a continuare a correre.
Grazie!
(Applausi)